з отримання штатів ставок і павла лазаренка
справа стала головну кар'єру количева
федерального прокурора США березні бірж
штати званого чого нового ринку закривав
бачимо його не і грушею шахрай ти з
банківськими рахунками коми та незаконних
наказів машів 200 мільйонів доларів за
сулія краще нам шляхом забув про volvo та
масштабне розслідування розпаду та березня
бірж у каїві від та корупційним
детективом та прокурором трирога
американці обрала довести утреця ти
край і до кольору
дуже жид ці речі і вийти на них не
слід буде вже складно
зокрема зомбі думати ще б'є з
банківських рахунків лазаренка було в
різьблених країнах банківська документація
вилазь із 12 марина мемом із суден та
розряд праворуч за ринку відриву в шутери
року
адвокат екс-прем'єра нова голосу з раку
над та американський суд у політичні
заодно живо насти праворуч через кого флік
лазаренка статичним президентом купою про
знижка beach is fiction
та доведено давав і українці прокурором
довелося ірод таємно перевіряти всю на
адже офіційну інформацію в я тобі мої
малий but if до образної тієї отрути ми у
тіні йому до козаки ми відривали в Україні
завжди б лавірує несе читати
аполітичний тис км над їх у сиф зекам ми
спимо проти лавра та уроки мошенник стовбура
за ринку так і вдалося довести хоч суд
визнала шаві сіез 5 10 2 пункті куб ви
взагалі не лекції бірж києву
викакав айвалик інтерес аеродрому з
кістки створити ненавидять і коло тину
детективи та прокурори в Україні дієти
таких маже 20 роки в тому
щоб dice la russe cloud від і кольором
клубів до корупції
диском потрібно мати душі
дуже хороший знання до покараю сюжетом по
англійському році ось а знання таким
чином серце перекидається хвої з
доводиться до бутан ти коло тіні
прокуратурі пари до ночі чашах райський
схема зараз і волога ринку
знайдуть змінилися детективи прокурори
дістати напої ки
а ви боротися з корупцією в Україні
зайди натискати
багата ж схеми завдяки нашим
розслідуванням припаяні але
домагаються їхати творить і я хочу раніше
я була відро баєш дракона 1 виростає
два запасні виходи темних підрахунок
розслідування садовий процес диво
лазаренко США тревал йому ж 7 рокки
теж і українським детективом треба до
зараз і ефективно реформи вати
системи суду шинство
to dive ж березня бішма там його результат